je reçois maintenant l'ex secrétaire
général de l'onu et oui vraiment merci
d'être là ça nous fait très plaisir de
vous avoir c'est un peu exceptionnel
donc on est content l'ex secrétaire
général de l'onu donc aujourd'hui
reconverti dans la francophonie boutros
boutros ghali pour la parution chez
fayard de son livre de son deuxième
livre mes années à la maison de verre
alors bonsoir monsieur boutros ghali
soit très heureux de vous avoir
donc en fait d'outreau se veut dire
pierre c'est ça oui hein
et alors le président sadate avec qui
vous avez travaillé pendant de longues
années
quand il était de bonne humeur et vous
appelez les boutros et puis quand il
s'appelait pierre c'est que tu es un peu
moins content c'est ça ma plaie pitt a
parce que je ne sais pas pourquoi
et alors l'interprétation qu'il avait
donné à menahem begin
ouais ce qu'il a une tête de pierre à
ouidah carte qu'il est compliqué pour
les cogner dessus de change d'avis c'est
vrai que vous êtes quelqu'un on va en
parler alors vos parents vous dites
parce que vos parents vous grande grande
et en français est une famille très très
cultivée du moyen-orient et du monde et
enfin ces papous faisait pour ne pas
nous humilier devant le peuple chinois a
mis d'accord mais c'était bien il
préserver votre amour-propre exact très
bien mais parfois ils comptent ils
voulaient que la grande grille soit plus
sévère il disait on a là un vide et donc
vous avez été secrétaire général de
l'onu on va en parler aujourd'hui vous
êtes sûr de la francophonie vous avez
fait des études en français alors
pourquoi ce livre la version originale
du livre et elle en anglais pourquoi
vous les payez directement en français
d'abord le jeu l'écrit en partie en
france est partie en anglais tout dépend
des documents que j'avais ma disposition
mais je tenais à m'adresser d'abord aux
lecteurs américains
s'il avait publié le livre en france
j'aurais beaucoup de difficultés à le
traduire un américain et à trouver un
éditeur
alors le contraire était plus facile de
le publier en amérique et donc je
m'adressais surtout les canaris car oui
dans la mesure je voudrais qu'ils
sachent que ce qu'attendait le bouquin
on sait
vous marchez pas vos mots pour un
diplomate vous irez assez fort d'air
alors s'appelle donc mes années à la
maison de verre c'est chez fayard comme
je les dis donc ça raconte votre
l'époque j'étais secrétaire général de
l'onu de 92 à 96 et alors à l'expiration
de votre premier mandat en 96
généralement on fait toujours de mandat
quand on est secrétaire général de l'onu
et vous où elle fait complètement
inhabituelle les états unis s'y sont
opposés malgré le soutien de dieu
soutient tout le monde la russie
l'angleterre les pays arabes et qui vote
au conseil de sécurité de 14 voix en
faveur de ma réélection
oui et un veto pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'après-guerre
l'utilisation du veto
ouais alors eux ils imposent que kofi
annan les américains qui est
effectivement on peut le croire en tous
les cas on l'a vu au sujet du kosovo
plus souple avec eux puisqu'il ya eu
comme on en parlera tout à l'heure
violation de la charte
alors des 92 quand même vous êtes le
premier secrétaire général de l'onu
d'origine du continent africain disons
vous déclarer je suis un homme libre et
indépendant et je n'ai aucun patron est
ce que vous pensez pas que ça a commencé
un peu à les énerver dès le début ça non
je pense que mes rapports étaient bons
débuts et comme je dis je n'ai aucun
patron je dis souvent si que je 185 4
ans mais il restait à ce moment le
nombre d'états mais ça ça vous
travaillez sous le regard de 185
ambassadeurs et vous dites finalement
c'est vraiment une maison de verre le nu
parce que je suis je suis sûr et je vais
tout surveiller mais mais je pense que
lorsque je disais que le secrétaire
général doit avoir un minimum
d'indépendance ceux ci étaient conformes
à la charte
c'est ce que le secrétaire général ne
doit pas de recevoir des instructions
d'un état ceci est aussi conforme à la
charte
alors dès le début vous découvrez quand
même que c'est pas facile dit la
bureaucratie est encore plus lourde que
la bureaucratie égyptienne et c'est pas
peu dire
alors vous y allez vous supprimez là je
raconte un peu pour montrer votre action
vous supprimez le cese poste de ministre
au lieu de 38 rapporteurs spéciaux vous
en gardez 10 vous fusionnez cinq
départements en un élan vous dit
moi mon métier c'était être provocant
dire que dès le début vous avez été
sentiment de fin d'étape sur la table il
fallait il fallait faire au début parce
qu'après ça vous commencez à vous à vous
habituer vos collaborateurs deviennent
des amis et il est beaucoup plus
difficile de pouvoir agir ici week-end
grâce aux départs des profiter de alors
en 95 les problèmes ont carrément de
votre réélection les problèmes
commencent avec les usa et vous dites
d'ailleurs à cette époque vous déclarez
les américains ils disent toujours faut
pas faire ceci il faut pas faire cela
enfin dès qu'on touche à leurs
privilèges
ils sont pas contents ils sont pas
d'accord donc là il ya déjà un petit un
petit sentiment de frottement entre les
américains et vous qui est exprimée mais
je dois vous avouer que j'ai eu des
flottements avec d'autres états puisque
à partir du moment où voulez vous
défendre l'indépendance le seul
personnage qui défendent vraiment
l'indépendance des nations unies c'est
le secrétaire général les états
utilisent les nations unies comme un
ustensile pour promouvoir leur propre
politique nationale
donc il est normal que je vais avoir des
difficultés pas seulement avec les états
unis mais avec d autres états membres et
qu'il y en avait eu à part les états
unis des problèmes plus en deuxième
position dans les problèmes régime
position j'ai eu des problèmes avec des
états qui me semble très familier j'ai
eu des problèmes avec l'état d'israël
j'ai eu des problèmes avec l'irak j'ai
eu des problèmes avec la france un
certain moment si vous vous rappelez la
presse française on disait la base des
généraux parce qu'on a changé de nom
généraux en bosnie donc j'ai eu des
problèmes avec plusieurs états mais ceci
dit il ne faut pas souligner le fait
d'avoir des problèmes je m'entendais
très bien avec les états unis sur
différents autre problème le problème
monsieur boutros ghali c'est qu'à un
moment vous la faire de votre réélection
devient une affaire de politique
intérieure américaine ses recettes au
moment de la lectio présidentielle
américaine
et là effectivement vous êtes soumis à
un feu nourri de critiques est
d'ailleurs bob dole c'est vous qui dites
ça bob doll
vous appelez boutros ce qui veut dire
bout ça veut dire où un ou comme ça aux
etats unis quand ils en france quand on
veut s'y plient quelqu'un 6 points en
egypte on frotte combien du sable au
propre les pieds ça fait un certain
bruit
en amérique on dit bon voilà alors mon
nom évidemment prêter alors il disait à
will never accepte d'accueillir tout le
monde applaudissait envoie un message
lui dit mon pain c'est de la
discrimination c'est presque
discrimination raciale c'est ce nom que
l'on peut monter imposer mes parents me
dit oui mais ça me rend tellement
populaire des élections la collection
démagogie mais vous êtes aussi arte à
madeleine albright dont vous avez dit
d'ailleurs je suis stupéfait par le
mépris et l'indifférence de madeleine
albright
ça dépend des moments s'entendent et
parfois et bien d'autres dans d'autres
circonstances nous étions total des
accords ouais vous payer un petit peu
votre côté de perturbateurs indépendant
et vous dites vous-même d'ailleurs
j'étais aussi bien contre le tout
ayatollahs que contre le tout coca cola
cela faisait signer vous au milieu comme
ça d'être le médiateur d'être le vous
savez je pense que si nous voulons que
les nations unies soient appelés à jouer
un rôle surtout face à la globalisation
il faut qu'elle ait un minimum
d'indépendance et je reviens à un
document que j'ai présentées s'en sert à
rien de vouloir promouvoir la démocratie
ce que je fais actuellement dans le
cadre de l'organisation internationale
de la francophonie
si au sommet vous avez un régime qui est
antidémocratique et autoritaire donc
comme vous avez la globalisation de
l'économie la globalisation des
communications vous devez aussi prévoit
de la globalisation de la démocratie
alors vous quittez l'onu finalement vous
êtes paré lulin et vous dites c'était un
vrai bras de fer qui m'a fait perdre que
moi même fait perdre sept kilos et mon
sens de l'humour ce qui d'après ma femme
était beaucoup plus grave
donc ça a été une épreuve pour vous on
sent bien d'ailleurs dans votre livre
je dis pas de l'amertume mais on sent
quand même que vous trouvez saint-just
square oui mais j'essaie surtout de
garder mon sens de l'humour si vous ne
perdez pas votre centre
ce moment où prenait au sérieux au fait
une dépression alors votre bilan est
plutôt positif sur le salvador le
mozambique le combat du guatemala la fin
de l'apartheid en afrique du sud
question comme ça incidente par rapport
à l'afrique du sud
est-ce que vous pendant tous tous ceux
qui sont d'origine les blancs d'origine
anglo saxonne retourne en angleterre
mais les afrikaners c'est la section
d'origine hollandaise veulent rester en
disant nous on est une tribu blanche
d'afrique et finalement il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on reste pas quand est arrivé
ici les personnes donc c'est à nous est
ce que comme envoyer l'avenir ces gens
là pfff je pense que c'est un problème
de réadaptation je pense que la présence
de nelson mandela à surmonter la phase
la plus difficile qui est la base la
transition et je pense que la nouvelle
équipe qui est au pouvoir et qui
bénéficie de l'image de nelson mandela
va pouvoir surmonter les difficultés
évidemment le problème qui se pose c'est
que vous avez une minorité blanche qui
est extrêmement riche et la grande
majorité noire qui est extrêmement
pauvre mais je pense que van hecke des
blancs vont rester en afrique du sud je
pense que des blogs
c'est effectivement ma question là vous
avez aussi créer les tribunaux
internationaux contre les crimes de
guerre de sujets de guerre de bosnie et
du rwanda
pendant les trucs quand un peu moins
bien marché enfin bon il ya l'ex
yougoslavie parce que des gens 94 vous
dire retirer les troupes de yougoslavie
l'angola la somalie le liberia ball
ainsi vous faire un bilan un peu
équitable oui mais vous avez il faudrait
mentionner autre chose ou quoi je les
mentionnaient dans ce livre c'est
conférence internationale que nous avons
obtenus qui dans une certaine mesure ont
adopté des normes qui vont régir le
prochain siècle
nous avons tenu une conférence au niveau
des chefs d'état à rio de janeiro pour
discuter des problèmes de
l'environnement pour la première fois
nous avons tenu une conférence à vienne
ce développement et droits de l'homme
nous avons tenu une conférence au caire
sur l'effet de l'explosion démographique
et le développement nous avons tenu une
conférence avec qui était a obtenu le
surtout l'accord du président mitterrand
à copenhague sur la dimension sociale du
développement d' avons tenu
conférence des femmes à pékin donc nous
avons tenu une série de consommer les
graines qui donneront des fruits aussi
d'un prochain qui ont déjà donné des
fruits je pense alors l'avenir de l'onu
évidemment tout le monde rêve d'un
gouvernement mondial qui fasse régner
l'ordre sur la planète c'est une utopie
mais les usa et ont une super puissance
on voit mal comment les usa accepterait
de donner tout ou partie de leurs
pouvoirs l'onu parce qu'on n'a jamais vu
personne qui donne le pouvoir sans y
être obligé par la force vous êtes
d'accord avec moi
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut envisager
finalement de l'avenir de l'onu toutes
les super puissances n'ont duré que un
siècle ou deux que ce soit l'empiré
romain ou l'empiré britannique
ensuite à partir du moment où vous allez
avoir d'autres super puissance qui va
naître je pense je reviens de chine je
pense à la chine si l'union européenne
s'intègre encore mieux ça devient une
autre superpuissance et ensuite il ne
faut pas seulement des superpuissances
il vous faut des états même des états
moyens qui ont la volonté politique de
s'intéresser aux affaires
internationales
à ce moment là vous avez un débat
politique à ce moment là vous avez un
échange quand même si vous trouvez crise
comme un peu moins le cas qu'à une
époque parce que moi je me souviens des
non-alignés avec ce qu'arnaud nasser et
c'est ça n'existe plus que c'est une
espèce de troisième pole à l'époque en
16es loisin ali et je suis d'accord avec
vous mais croyez moi que si vous avez un
état qui connaît bien ses dossiers qui
s'intéresse aux appels internationale
alors à ce moment il peut discuter
la puissance américaine vient d'une part
de la puissance percée des états unis
mais elle vient aussi de la résignation
des autres états et du de l'indifférence
du repli dans le pli choix d'un manque
d'intérêt public en identitaire est ce
que vous êtes d'accord
est ce que vous pensez donc à terme
l'onu va prendre plus de pouvoir sur la
planète ou qu'au contraire ce sera
toujours sous les fourches caudines sont
obligés de passer sous les fourches
caudines d'une totale devrait inventer
si l'onu ne replonge passe à poissons
devra inventer d'autres organisations
internationales qui devront régir la
mondialisation parce que vous avez
différentes mondialisation qui ont
chacune leurs propres spécificités
donc il s'agit de trouver des organes
pour gérer ses mondialistes datation
alors les états unis l'ont quand même
toujours pas payés ils ont toujours des
arrières et il paye pas en plus n'ont
ils pas leur contribution il pas j'avais
dit que si lens est déjà parti pour les
payer il en va payer quand même pas une
pop et comme en plus ils sont pas
honnêtes et alors il ya eu coup sûr vous
évidemment où on a parlé en a parlé tout
à l'heure c'est à dire que comme une
violation de la charte des nations unies
ça vous n'étant plus là c'était plus
facile pour eux et comment vous voyez
l'intervention des états unis aux
nations unies pardon au timor bien ces
gens là on leur dit voter ça y est c'est
la liberté c'est formidable aller voter
pide qu'ils ont voté on les laisse être
massacrés par les militants de noyage
est en manque de préparation il a fallu
prévoir
il faudrait avoir une présence militaire
avant les élections aient refusé de
faire des élections s'il n'y avait pas
une présence militaire je ne sais pas si
ça a été une bonne idée de faire un
référendum tout de suite demain
apparemment dans une région isolée
laisser du temps
n'oubliez pas que vous avez un certain
nombre de d'habitants de timor qui
vivent en indonésie ouais ouais donc ça
ne va leur poser des problèmes
n'oubliez pas aussi que ce qui s'est
passé à timor peut donner exemple à des
sécessions analogues dans des centaines
de reims il est ce que nous avons
intérêt à contribuer à la décomposition
d'un état aussi grand que l'indonésie
surtout qu'il est facile à émietter
puisque c'est beaucoup dire exactement
alors très bien merci
maintenant on va parler un petit peu de
vous plus précisément dix on a moins de
votre action vous êtes
riches familles coptes alors il faut
expliquer peut-être un peu pour nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est à dire que vous
n'êtes pas musulman égyptien mais non
musulmans ils côté vous avez à peu près
l'egypte était chrétienne jusqu'au vième
siècle
et puis à hull invasions arabes et du 6e
au xxème siècle l'egypte a été peu à peu
islamisée il est resté à une poche qui
elle a maintenu la religion qui était
qui a créé la tradition monastique en
egypte sont les coptes et qui continuent
ils représentent à peu près 10% de la
population alors ballon vous avez 7
millions à vue millions de cols
qu'est-ce qui souffrent de
l'islamisation non non ils coexistent
depuis le 6e siècle et ça donc ils ont
dû trouver différents qui les dote de
deux coexistent votre grand père
s'appelait pierre boutros ghali n'est
pas boutros boutros ghali lui alors il
était miami et boutros à ne jamais
utiliser mon pied à mon vélo ce lundi au
jeudi et pierre il a été le premier
premier ministre non musulman donc
d'égypte malheureusement d'ailleurs été
assassinés donc vous fait vos études
là-bas à héliopolis et en 46 48 vous
venez à paris je sais pas si mes
informations sont bonnes mais vous
habitez rue monsieur le prince
oui et alors vous êtes un peu playboy
ravageur c'est vrai ça exagéré en trois
ans j'ai fait mes deux diplômes de
l'homme de droit public diplôme
d'économie diplôme de sciences
politiques et terminer une thèse de
doctorat
ouais donc en 13 ans tellement pour la
gaudriole
j'ai essayé mais je ris beaucoup de
courage bien donc en 52 en egypte ya un
événement c'est nasser et 90% des biens
de votre famille sont nationalisées
malgré tout vous restez dans la dent
dans le nassérisme enfin je vous
finissez par adhérer au parti unique à
un moment certainement j'étais j'ai
enseigné à l'université du caire et
alors il y avait une obligation c'était
un système quand même qu'il ressemblait
beaucoup au système communiste c'était
une obligation si vous voulez enseigné
de faire partie du prime
donc j'ai été d'office nommé membre du
parti et est à ce titre que j'ai essayé
que ce soit dans la traverse des revues
que j'avais créé ou décès de freiner
cette tendance vers une gauche
extrémiste qui ne correspond pas à la
mentalité égyptienne et qui donnerait le
pouvoir à une bureaucratie qui par
définition est innocente et qui
deviendra à partir du moment où elle
gère ses biens deviendra corrompue alors
en 77 vous êtes nommé donc fini des
affaires étrangères avoue travailler que
sa date avec hosni moubarak en 91 vice
premier ministre et en 92 le nu voilà à
peu près brossé votre carrière qui est
fort fort brillante
alors une question on sait qu'on est
dans une émission culturelle on parle
beaucoup de littérature ici vos deuxième
femme donc s'appelle leye à mariana de
l'air on dit qu'elle a été le modèle de
clé à dont le livre de durel le captur
d'alexandrie alors et vous vous seriez
un peu le modèle du prince naseem ici
bon alors vous vous dites c'est pas vrai
parce que j'avais vous étiez dans la
croix vous avez dit s'attendre à croire
c'est pas vrai j'avais seulement 14 ans
quand dur elle a publié son livre alors
moi ce qui est bien c'est pas vrai non
plus parce que dure l île a publié son
livre 57 et xavier 35 ans donc vous
pourriez très bien être nessim découvrir
les autres je vais raconter notre
histoire et dans tous les ouvrages vous
êtes vous avez avc persuadé que c'est
moi l'initiative l'initiateur de la
de la visite de sadate à jérusalem ce
n'est pas vrai j'aurais bien et est très
fier de sa vie mais ce n'est pas vrai si
j'avais prenez dans des articles
rapprochement entre israéliens et
égyptiens l'importance d'un dialogue
mais j'étais le dernier à savoir qu'il
allait faire une visite géruzet comme il
m'a demandé de faire le discours j'ai
fait le discours qui n'a jamais utilisé
mon discours aussi fait donc vous avez
dans les sims est pas vous vous seriez
fier d'être s'il ya des légendes qui
vous avez beau dire ce n'est pas vrai
village vous aviez pas quatorze ans que
je viens simplement si vous aviez 35 ans
à l'époque où le bouquin et a été publié
le bouc apparu en 57
non il n'a pas dû un bon avant je
vérifie alors vous et des surnoms comme
ça on vous appelle le crocodile du nil
et on vous appelle le phare en lequel
vous préférez entre l'onil européenne du
nil et le faron c'est ce sont des
fonctionnaires qui sont mécontents de la
façon dont j'ai géré les nations unies
qui tantôt m'appelait le phalanx tantôt
appelé le crocodile
ouais bah quand je ferme et certaines
administrations où je mettais un certain
temps que j'étais devenu le crocodile
ouais je pense que la france va mal oui
ça fait un peu arrogant quand vous vous
êtes un excellent diplomate bien tourner
votre carrière le prouve mais il ya une
phrase que vous concernant sur laquelle
j'aimerais bien que vous réagissiez pour
terminer notre entretien
c'est quand ils cherchent un peu en
parlant de vous quand il cherche un
homme de confiance il commence par se
regarder dans le miroir
lorsqu'en vous serrez pas vrai mais je
sais très bien qu'on est raillé le plus
souvent par les siens il se perd vos
plus proches collaborateurs et il faut
accepter ceci avec un grand sourire en
positif inertie entrée 15 quand j'aurai
beaucoup apprendre de vous remercie
beaucoup
ici ben voilà on continue en je
m'appelle le titre du livre c'est mes
années la maison de verre c'est
passionnant c'est chez fayard en est au
coeur de l'action
c'est la première fois qu'un secrétaire
général de l'onu nous fait pénétrer
comme ça dans son travail parce que
jusque là c'était un peu plus secret
voilà merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu